35 percent of sugar-free soft drinks
contain the artificial sweetener
aspartame and since it was first
approved for use in the 1970s it's been
marketed as a way of reducing obesity
and avoiding diabetes but they've been
persistent questions over whether
aspartame can cause cancer now the World
Health organization's cancer research
agency irk says the answer to that
question is possibly but only if you
consume huge quantities
having an acceptable daily intake it
means it is acceptable to consume a
certain amount of aspartame without
having appreciable health effects irk
classed aspartame as a possible cancer
risk based on three scientific studies
on humans which found limited evidence
that aspartame might be linked with a
specific type of liver cancer even
though the same studies couldn't exclude
other factors such as lifestyle
socioeconomics or even just coincidence
the international Council of beverages
associations says that system is overly
cautious once something enters the iarc
review process there is no option to
find that it is not a cancer Hazard irk
has previously found that items such as
aloe vera night shift work and hot water
are cancer hazards
so how much is safe well this can of
diet cola contains around 200 milligrams
of aspartame and according to the
guidelines my safe limit per day is
around 3 300 milligrams now that means I
would have to be drinking at least this
much diet soda 17 cans every single day
before aspartame became a cancer risk
there is no convincing evidence that
aspartame causes cancer in humans so if
you occasionally have a diet fizzy drink
or other foods that contain aspartame as
part of a healthy balanced diet there
really is no need to change anything or
to worry about what might happen
nonetheless the who is keeping an eye on
aspartame this is not the final verdict
the scientists point out that the
limited evidence to link aspartame to
cancer simply underscores the need for
more and better research Paul Brennan Al
Jazeera London